you've probably heard it a hundred times
by now that climate change is a national
security threat and we've talked a
little more specifically about the types
of national security threat that climate
change is we've talked about it from a
military perspective I've talked about
these sort of economic implications
which also make climate change a
national security threat we've talked
about the threat of having usable land
in our country being an important thing
for national security and how climate
change can endanger that it's pretty
obvious to any clear-thinking and
rational person that climate change
threatens our national security in any
number of ways as I often like to say
you can argue about the source of
climate change you can debate well what
should our policy and response to
climate change be but it is a national
security threat full-stop Donald Trump
is going to remove climate change from
the list of threats on his national
security strategy which is set to be
released today maybe by the time you
listen to this story or watch it on TV
maybe he has already done that
what will Donald Trump's national
security strategy document focus on
instead border security and economic
competitiveness legitimate issues but
climate change is still a national
security threat we are a laughingstock
and in producing the show it gets more
and more difficult to react with an
actual story and an analysis to this
stuff rather than just laughing or maybe
crying would be a more reasonable
reaction look no further than our own
military Donny boy not exactly an
organization the American military that
we can write off as sort of tree-hugging
bleeding heart liberals our own military
considers climate change to be a
national security threat why won't Trump
listen to his quote generals as he is
called the many times now the Department
of Defense has been saying that climate
is a security risk for years now the
Pentagon continues to plan for the
threat that climate change presents to
the United States and of course Trump
doesn't actually respect the military we
know that because if he did he
wouldn't have picked fights with the
widows of deceased soldiers he wouldn't
have picked fights with gold star
parents Trump doesn't respect the
military as evidenced by his numerous
promises to make donations to veterans
charities which basically he hasn't done
other than the one he was shamed into
doing that $25,000 check to a gold star
family so the question really is whether
this is pandering or self-interest from
Trump in removing the United States of
national security threats on the one
hand there are likely ways that as a
real estate developer you want to be
able to do whatever the hell you want
and regulations that sort of account for
climate change probably limit your
freedom as a real estate developer but
on the other hand it might just be
pandering to that shrinking 30-something
percent of the country that supports
Donald Trump because they're skeptical
of climate change which I call they are
divorced from reality on climate change
might just be a combination of the two
for him could just be out of spite - I
mean it's not like there's a benchmark
or a limit and how many threats you have
to list on that document that's true so
he could add economic productivity and
border security without having to take
away climate change
yeah and for that that's the go against
Obama at any opportunity argument right
the idea of going against anything that
President Obama did of course it was
President Obama as Pat is alluding to
who added climate change to the list of
national security threats it didn't work
out well for Trump going against
everything Obama did when he decided to
ignore Obama's a suggestion not to hire
Michael forth that one did not work out
particularly well for Donald Trump we'll
see what the impact is of this one but a
big deal and just a really bad thing
because it's not zero-sum you can leave
national security I'm sorry you can
leave climate change on the list of
national security threats and still say
that you want to renewed focus on
whatever else economic stuff border
security whatever it is that you want to
put on there it is probably a
combination of incompetence pandering
selfishness and spite as producer pat is
pointing out here as well the video you
just finished watching was made possible
by you
the membership program you can sign up
for membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership